gone. What is influential now?
Influencers. Okay, Sneo. I watched Nico
convert to Islam. Yeah, I don't know why
he converted to Islam. He's gay. So,
he's convert to Islam. What is he on
about, bro? Bro, it's like, you know,
for the last 5 minutes, he's been saying
Yakar's done this and this person's done
this and Patrick bet David sitting there
scratching his armpits. Yeah. And not
not challenging him at all. Like, he's
wasted all all that time flying there to
just ask him a few crappy questions.
He's not challenging him at all. So now
Tommy Robinson, that one functioning
brain cell that was rattling around in
his head like a skittle, even that's
given up now as well. And he's just
talking nonsense now, frankly.
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran. Gives you reminders. Download
the Qurani app now and let it testify
for you on your Makyama that you read it
wherever you was. Asalamaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends,
Patrick Pet and Islamophobe as worse as
Tommy Robinson decided to fly to Tommy
Robinson. People used to travel like you
said in another for knowledge it for
knowledge but he's traveling to decrease
his knowledge to lose knowledge to lose
knowledge. Yeah. Cuz Tom can't get to
the USA because the people at the top
are they're jealous. They want to take
him down cuz they're speaking the truth.
No, because he went to he tried to get
into US with a fake passport. Oh, okay.
In Canada he went to prostitutes. In UK
he does cocaine parties and that
escalated quickly. It did. It did. And
so yeah, it's not because he wants
people trying to stop him. No. So he
flew out to a specific island just to
interview him. So you can see the agenda
behind. Was it Epstein's island? Um I
won't be surprised. I would not be
surprised at all. It might be, it might
not be. We don't know this. Okay, let's
go. Here we go. If the police went in
and tried to stop then there's a riot
and the police know it. So constantly
they just allow it that you saw the
Palestinian demonstrations. You saw the
hatred, the calling for gasing the Jews.
Literally the most hatred we've seen on
our streets of our capital city. And the
police are standing there, big smiles on
their faces. Yeah, if it was a British,
how much influence do Jews have in in in
UK? Just one question question to Tom
Robinson. Can you please provide or show
a legitimate like a protest happening
and there's they're spewing hatred
against Jews? Not the Zionist, not the
Zionist. Not because they they're
colonizers, not because they're settlers
and not the odd person. Yes. Not that's
making a comment here and there because
we can do that with every march. We want
the theme of the march to be about this
because we we all know what happened in
America when a woman did a uh Nazi
salute and then she ended up being a
Jewish owner of two cafes.
Do you see? So sometimes Exactly. So
bring if you say you you're not a lie,
you're telling the truth, please bring
it. More community in the UK. Now
there's obviously the conspiracy which
comes from the the genuine Nazis and far
right that the Jews control everything.
I think if they control everything and
they're controlling the media, they're
not doing a very job, are they? Because
everything's attacking them. and and and
yeah, because there was a tweet exchange
between you and um you and Dan Bzerian,
I believe, Rob, if you want to pull that
one up. There was um Do you have it? Do
you know which one I'm talking about?
Where slavery money and then you
responded back to him um uh uh uh let's
see which one it is. I'll pull it up
here. Uh he said, "You will remain a
slave as long as you worship." May 31st.
He said this at one of Tate's tweets.
You respond back said, "Iran's [__]
talking about escaping slavery." They
has been very critical of Jews. Right.
Very. And I don't know if Tate's Do you
and Tate have a relationship together?
So me and Tate before he was Tate um
we're from the same town. So yeah we do
yeah we're friends friends still today.
Friends still today. Still today. So so
what's happened is this is my view. So
so he talks about Dan Bizerian says now
everything there's not everything I
agree with everything he says but the
point is this. If there's anyone does
anyone's [__] excuse my language. Tommy
Robinson you are the biggest [__] to
Zionism and Israel and you've made that
like so much so that you call yourself a
patriot. You put Israel and Zionism
before your own people. But even bro,
even before you say that, it's they make
it seem like this is some absurd weird
thing. This guy's been in prison. He's
missed a lot of thing that's that's been
happening. maybe because he's been
watching these inappropriate sites or
whatnot just to pass the time, but he
should know that the chairman of the
Republican Jewish Coalition and former
US Senator US Senator former Norm
Coleman,
he alongside Durowitz have admitted,
"Yeah, we do we do control these
things."
What's his name? Zuckerberg, he's with
us. Scott Scott uh Alolman, the guy who
owns the chat GPT and so on and so
forth. So these are the people that
constantly make these claims. So we're
not saying it. We're saying, can you
speak to your friends there? Because you
said you're Zionist first and you would
fight for Israel first. So can you speak
to your to you guys there? And you
haven't gone to the IDF, by the way, to
fight. I don't know why. Yeah. Because
you said if something was to happen,
you'd be there. Now that you've left
prison, get off your island and off you
pop. Yeah. Yeah. Cuz you're a little
wimp. You can't go anywhere. You
flipping intellectual [__] Like if
you look at Qatar spend, you know, I I
want to preface this. The reason why I'm
saying this is if Jews are as powerful
as they are and they own all these
politicians around the world. How is UK
in the state that it is where Muslims
are able to do what they're doing with
getting away with it? If Jews So first,
the premise is this. Who where did you
get this Muslims are doing what they're
doing? What are Muslims doing and what
are they getting away with? What the
hell are you talking about? If there is
anyone that's getting away with
genocide, mass murder, hitting sovereign
countries, Yes. and controlling America
with Apac. Yes. And buying out these
sellouts. Yes. It's the Zionist. So, I'm
confused. The premise here is if Where
did you even get this truth that Muslims
What are Muslims doing in the U? What
what's he talking about? It It doesn't
make any sense, bro. On on the one week
we're banning the burka getting banned,
but we're not we're not talking about
banning any Jewish clothing. The other
week we're talking about halal week
possibly getting halal meat possibly
getting banned. Nothing being mentioned
about kosher meat. Then offcom Yeah.
They on financial times they're saying
the headline is Muslims treated
differently by newspapers says press
watch dog. Yeah. So when the newspapers
are constantly spewing anti-Muslim
stuff, you got politicians like Sella
Brahman, Serge Javeed and the likes.
Now, even Boris Johnson just calling
remember when he was calling Muslim
women letter boxes and the guy nothing
happened to him. But when it comes to
somebody saying stuff about Jewish
people like recently, this guy is not
even a politician. Yeah. David Williams
does a salute. Yeah. A Nazi salute. He's
doing a joke or something like that.
It's all over the news. It's a problem.
Yeah. You've got this guy saying this in
his lyrics, the baby saying this, or
this individual saying this. Um, what's
his name? Uh, Wy saying what he's doing.
It's all over the news. Front page,
everyone's discussing it. But
Islamophobic comments, people can say
them all day long. Some farright guy is
going to say these guys don't believe in
free speech, mate. No one would say that
to even Priti Patel, somebody did a
cartoon of her looking like a cow. It
was on the French p. It was it was in
the earlier pages of people saying this
is harmful. This is disrespectful to her
religion. I thought you couldn't speak
about Muslims though. I thought they
were forbidden like this. Oh, okay.
Interesting. This much power. Well,
they're not. It's an easy way out to
blame the Jews for everything. Yeah. So
even Muslims, even when it comes to ISIS
or terrorists, they say, "Are they
Jewish groups? Everything's Jewish
groups. Oh, that's a full flag. That was
a Jews terrorist because it's nothing to
do with ourselves as Jews as well.
Everything's Jews." Now, with the
anti-Jew hatred, I think Mine Camp hit
this book. They don't say it's a Jewish
group. Yes. What they say is why is it
that they've never attacked Israel and
they're too busy attacking their own
Muslim brothers? That's the thing that
they say. That's number one. Number two,
and you can search this up on Harets,
why is it that when something happens to
ISIS, Israelis are taking them into
their hospitals and then treating them?
Yes. Exactly. These are questions. Are
we allowed to ask questions? Do we have
free speech, Mr. Robinson? Who attacked
USS Liberty? JF Kennedy? Yes. There the
laughing the laughing uh Jews when 911
happened. I mean look ask some questions
my friend. Wait a we wait for them for
the false flag attack which you're going
to be mentioning island who he was
working for Mosad. Yes. Bringing in
these Harvey Weinstein the Hollywood
producer that keeps touching women. Yes.
Exactly. We're just making up. Of course
it's 7% you hatred. The Quran is 11%.
Take Israel out of the equation.
Muhammad hated the Jews. Whoa. Whoa.
Whoa. Did he just say take Israel out of
the equation? Oh, wa. Anti-semite. N
anti-semite. N now I I get called a
Zionist. I get called a Zionist all the
time. No, sorry.
What do you mean? I get called a
Zionist. You call yourself a Zionist.
You tripping [__] Yes. What a [__]
Me all the time saying funded by I've
never received any funded. I just give
my honest opinion. Israel was surrounded
by totalitarian Islam. Did children
support you or Robert Ch? I've never
spoke to Robert saying, "Oh yeah,
they're definitely they're definitely
stupid. They're going to definitely come
and uh um fund you directly. They're
going to do indirectly. No, I forgot a
Yeah.
Well, they I thought you remember the
references.
Nice. Come on. Anything like that? I I
worked So, and I had this with so say
like who does Diljang, whatever his name
is. Is he making money on YouTube? Cuz
if he is, the owners of YouTube are
Zionist, which means he's receiving
funding from Zinus. That's what they've
done to me. So, I worked for Ezra Lean.
I've never met Robert.
Ezra Lean.
Who's Ezra? Ezra. Zionist. Ezra. He's a
Zionist on Rebel Media. You used to work
for him. Yes. You know, like he's a
Zionist control. He's got media uh
outlet and he would be doing what? What
would he be pushing out? Didn't Kanan
Robinson when we interviewed him say who
used to work for you that you used to be
happy when he was working for rebel
media anytime a terrorist stack up by
Islamist Islamic ISIS whatever. Yeah.
You were happy that your own people were
getting killed by these nuts nutters and
you was happy because it fulfilled your
agenda. That's kind of what kind of scum
you were. Ezra is a rebel media Jewish
in Canada. I worked for him. It was
£5,000 a month wage. Yeah. And because
Bob Shman gave donations or funding to
Ezra. I've never met him. Never. Oh,
listen. You didn't meet him, bro.
Listen, he didn't get paid. It's like me
getting paid by Iran or Saudi, but it's
not directly from Muhammad bid Salman,
bro. It's through his uncle's cousins
agency that works in a newsletter shop
and he gave it through a sweet. Like,
it's like, yeah, but I never got paid.
Are you Do you think we're stupid? Do
you think we're dumb? You are number
one. You are the biggest funded one of
the biggest funded individuals. Yes.
Okay. And why? Because of your false
agenda. It's it's it's as clear as that.
So don't lie. Dan Bizerian, he's a
self-made I don't know how he's made is
a millionaire for that matter. And he's
not paid by anybody for that matter. So
it gets interesting. It comes to Sneo
and Andrew Tate. Let's carry on. The
same as in fact any company. If you pick
any company and you look somewhere,
there'll be some Jewish person involved
in it. They say you're receiving funding
from from Jews. That's what they've
done. Now, what are you what do you
believe in? Are you a Christian? Are you
a Jew? What would you say? Do you
believe in God? Yeah. I'm a Christian.
You're a Christian. I'm a Christian.
Yeah, I've been pushed more. So I used
to say that I didn't believe. My mom was
Catholic brought up. But then as I've
seen the attacks on Christianity and
I've also seen the decay in British
society and the fall of Britain has come
from the fall of belief. We have since
we've stopped believing and what built
Great Britain Christianity what built
everything about us. Everything about
our nation that everyone wants to come
to it and make it a success was built on
Christianity. Since that's descended,
since it's been coming under attack
since people have left it, it's left a
void and that void's being filled. And
if we want to understand and remember
who we are as part of our identity, he's
even afraid to say filled by what? By
what? By Islam. See, he's he's afraid
it's filled by Islam. you know, he sees
it as a massive frai. I think in prison
he was like, "How how is Islam growing
so fast?" It's like, I believe it's
false. I think this really shakes him.
He doesn't even want to mention it.
Since we left Christianity, it's been
the void's been fulfilled by finish
sentence. It just moves on by Islam. And
you know what's interesting? He's not
going to mention the fact that the UK
made a lot of its money from slavery,
from colonization. colonization 200
years of Hindustan India, Pakistan,
Bangladesh that used to be top one of
the top when it came to economy and when
the Brits left they bought and uh they
they literally pillaged that country.
It's to such a degree that even the
Americans had enough of the British and
they went and they started their own
country because they were getting
oppressed by the UK so much. Till today
they celebrate Independence Day.
Independence Day from whom? from here,
from the UK. Is this Christian values?
Crusaders. And you guys need to search
this up. All you need to search is
crusaders eating Muslims. Do you know
this? No. Yes. Eating. Yes. You know
what? We We need to get to the bottom.
Crusaders
eating Muslims. Savage. That's what we
call savage. It's called the siege of
Mahara. Yeah. Wow. The siege of Mahara.
Yeah, it's infamous for claims of
widespread cannibalism committed by the
crusaders. Don't chat to me ever again.
Don't chat to me ever again about
Christian values. Yeah, Tommy. Yeah,
we're going to come to that, by the way,
because Christianity does have good
values. I'm talking about Tommy
Robinson's version of Christianity that
I know a lot of you people disagree
with. So, let me make that clear.
I say to some people, if you don't
believe in Christianity, you don't have
to believe in Jesus. That's what built
us as a nation. That that must be
protected. That's part of our identity.
But when it comes to the whole the
Israel and Jew things, I think Qatar, if
you look at Qatar, Qatar spent nearly
three quarters of a billion pound in
funding Islamic organizations across
Europe. Radical. Radical jihadist
mindset. Qatar are behind it. They've
been allowed to buy every port in our
country. They own half of half of
London. Our politicians have sold their
souls to Qatar. Yeah. And guitar come
in. Now, what Qatar used to do in these
these countries used to, they used to
fund little charities, Islamic
charities, and they'd fund them to be on
the streets calling for da. Okay. I we
we're on the streets calling for da.
I've been doing this for about 13 years.
I have not got a single pen from kata. I
don't I don't know what this guy's
talking about. I know many da tables by
the way. Many of them. Yeah. I don't
know any of them. Some of them actually
struggle. Yes. Okay. We don't get paid.
So what the is he talking about, bro?
Listen, every accusation is a
confession. Okay. You get paid. So
you're bring into this. What are you
talking about? The the thing is that he
he talks about getting paid. He's like,
"No, no, no. I got paid by Ezra." Yeah,
but but Ezra got paid by Robert Shman.
That's number one. And he didn't mention
the fact that he was when he was jailed,
Middle East Forum, who's the former
employee of the Israeli Minister of
Defense, Greg Roman, he admitted in a
statement to financing him, organizing
his protest, fees and bringing foreign
pressure to secure his release. I wonder
why. I wonder why. Cuz they love Tommy.
Well, that's gone. What is influential
now? Influencers. Okay, Sneo. I watched
Nico convert to Islam. Yeah. I don't
know why he converted to Islam. He's
gay. So he's convert to Islam. What is
he on about, bro? Bro, it's like, you
know, for the last five minutes, he's
been saying Yakar's done this and this
person's done this and Patrick bet David
sitting there scratching his armpits.
Yeah. And not not challenging him at
all. Like he's wasted all all that time
flying there to just ask him a few
crappy questions. He's not challenging
him at all. So now Tommy Robinson, that
one functioning brain cell that was
rattling around in his head like a
skittle, even that's given up now as
well. And he's just talking nonsense
now, frankly. Oh yeah, he's a
homosexual. I'm a chocolate biscuit.
Hey, look, there's a marshmallow sky.
And and not only that, what's your point
with this? I don't understand him being
gay. Okay, one second. That's me. That's
false. No, even before that, he talks
about, "Oh, I don't know why he even
accepted Islam." You do know because you
just said me and Andrew Tate are still
Muslims. He's he's a Muslim. So you
obviously do you have a problem with it
or you don't have a problem with it that
you're talking about? He's saying, "Oh,
how can Sneo accept Islam when he's
gay?" Hold on a second, my friend. You
are you follow You um um You are gay.
You are you gay? Yes. You the LGBTQ
movement allegedly. You are a Christian.
Yeah, exactly. Listen to my listen to
me. You followed you. You're pro LGBTQ.
Yes. But hold on a second. I think
you're a Christian. Can you be Christian
and gay? No, you can't. You know you
can't. You listen to my friend Tommy
Robson. If I saw you on the streets as a
Christian man now, you're finished, my
friend. You're finished. Wahali, you're
finished. You're done, my friend.
Because you know why? You're supporting
the gay community. No, no, no. Ali, no.
No, no. I can't let you carry on like
this because look, I know they there's a
King James version of the Bible, but
there's also a Queen James version of
the Bible. I think it's the Queen James
version of the Bible that he follows.
That's what it is because that before.
Yeah, it's very vital. Well, I've
watched a video from him saying, "Well,
I wasn't sure if I was gay or not."
Yeah. If you're not sure if you're gay
or not, sneak you gay. Yeah, it's very
simple. Okay, that's what his words, not
mine. So, I'm I'm just going by his
words. Yeah. But I watch Sneo and then
he converts to Islam cuz it becomes
trendy. Remember, people like us telling
the truth about Islam. We were attacked
in silence and then Islam comes involves
money and it becomes very trendy. Yeah.
And it becomes trendy cuz all the
money's coming funding it. Now Sneo
converts and then he goes to make some
video in Saudi Arabia. Very well
produced video. He's drawing the
American youth. You need to wake up. One
second. One second. There is no
evidence. We have full evidence that you
are financed by the Zionist. There is no
evidence that Sneo has ever been paid.
Yes. by the by any any government. None.
None. None. And when it comes to gay, we
have to be honest, bro. You are
exhibiting more of the evidence that you
are gay. You've just you just come out
of prison and you weren't walking
properly. He's going to watch He's going
to watch this. Yeah. Are you gay? You
You are gay. Why are you gay? Allegedly.
Yeah. Yeah. Allegedly. Yeah. So, uh what
was the other thing that he was saying?
Are you gay?
Now, there was another point I was going
to make. So, about Sneo Yeah. getting
paid uh the government. Huh. So, okay.
So, he's saying, "Yeah, he did it to to
gain fame and this." Okay. Let's let's
analyze the fame that Sneo's got. So,
Sneak's on Rumble. Uh we we all know
Rumble is like when people are banned
from platforms. The other one is X.
Okay, let's start the list. That's it.
Yeah. He's not on Instagram. He's not on
Facebook. He's not on YouTube. He's not
on Snapchat. He's not allowed on these
platforms. Yeah. Tik Tok, you name it.
So why why would he why would he come?
Even when you look at his videos, his
videos are very similar. He's just
started and adopted a new kind of style.
But other than that, he's even recently
in the Warner when he did the live
stream, Sneo's there with, you know,
that um that bike that you have to pay
to use it. Yeah. What's the evidence
that that guy is rolling with the Arab
money? Yeah. There's nothing like this.
He thinks everyone's like Yeah. the same
with Andrew Tate. Okay. These people in
my view, so many of the people I see
these Tik Tokers now after after October
some I saw back to Tik Tok in America
and she's got the Quran and I've just
decided to pick up the Quran and start
reading it. I think [__] off, how much
paid for that? Yeah. So to get the
influence with the next generation of
youth, she he can you know what it is
with him? He's like, "It is impossible
for someone to rationally logically
accept Islam." And if they do, to him
it's like, "No, it cannot be." He it to
him, it does not make sense. I don't
understand. He's saying, "Why on earth
would somebody pick up the Quran?" Well,
he wrote a book. Yeah. Well, it was
mostly written by Peter Mclofflin, but
if you look,
can you see Can you see here? Yeah. Can
you see here? Look the top yellow and
the bottom yellow. Yeah, that's what
they've written. The rest of that is
just a copy paste of the Quran. Say that
that white bit. Look, it's just Quran.
It's just Quran. Look, chapter 69.
Unbelievable. They've just re they just
reorganized it and edited it. Now, how
do you do that without picking up the
Quran? Who told you to pick up the
Quran? No, but I did it for this reason.
Yeah, they did it for the reason that
they want to find out what's in the
Quran. Exactly. It's called knowledge
building. Just because you're reading a
book doesn't mean you have to agree with
it, Tommy Robinson. And surely if you're
coming on TV and you're making this
argumentation, surely you should be
doing a bit of reading. And had you done
a bit of reading, your sentence would be
a bit more coherent than they are. So
with the next generation of youth, if
you people convert to Islam and take
convert to Islam, do come out of prison
holding the Quran. Do you know all these
things? So when Andrew Tate came out of
prison, so many people started accepting
Islam and they were holding the Quran.
What happened when Tommy Robinson came
out of prison looking like a Muslim?
Exactly. Not a single person converted
to Christianity. I think he's just
jealous. He's like, "I came out of
prison. Nothing happened. I had to flee
to an island. I came out of prison with
a sore backside
for the but all of these people the way
they now reach the public as in there
are billions of pounds to be spent in
order to convert people to Islam. In my
in my town center, there's a shop called
Discover Islam. Yeah. It's a shop that's
funded. Its sole purpose is to convert
non-Muslims to Islam. And bro, I went to
that shop. You know, it's funny because
I went there with the guy did prayer
mats. Yeah. By the way, Tom said, I went
there and there was, bro, there were so
many reverts. There was one sister, uh,
Polish sister who said she learned the
entire salah through our mats. Yeah. A
fantastic place. I know the brother who
is carrying the operations and we supply
them with the mats. Tommy, if you want
to meet me there, please let me know
what time in I'll be there. So, you just
you're just butt hurt, bro. Islam is
growing. You just cannot deal with it,
bro. Islam and that's in every town city
across the UK. There's a mass and they
work with the council. So if America do
not wake up to the power and the
influence coming in from the money from
Saudi Arabia, they're going to convert
your youth. And when they convert your
youth through the prison system on the
streets, they're going to turn them so
quickly and so fast against America.
They're right. They're going to turn
them so quickly against drugs. Yes.
Pornography. Yes. Sexual abuse. Yes. U
alcohol, gambling. Okay. They're going
to become real individuals who have real
lives who serve a specific purpose. Uh
rather than if you're going to talk
about a tournament against America, my
friend, Zionists are fun. Look, look,
America is owned by Zionist. Apac, we
know that very clearly. So, it's it's
it's unbelievable. You call about
democracy and all of these senses, all
these people are bought out. So, if
there's anyone funding money, you know,
it's like every accusation is a
confession. Bro, look at they they talk
about human shields, bro. Mossad, the
headquarters are in in in a a densely
populated area. Everything they accuse
the Palestinians or whoever, they do it
theirel. This guy is full-blown funded
and he's attacking everyone with the
argument that is purely against him.
You're the one that's being funded, man.
You've accused Bizarian, Andrew Tate,
Sneo, myself, Kataris, this that. No
evidence. No evidence. The margin
anti-Jewish. No evidence. Nothing. All
he's doing is talking. And this clown
here, this flipping Chihuahua, Patrick
Pet, he's a little pet. Yeah. He's just
letting him talk. You know, I don't know
if you if you zoomed in to the bottom
left, you can see Patrick Bet David.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He's just he's
scrolling on social media. He's so
Tommy's so boring that the guy is just
scrolling. He's just checking out
videos. No, no, not only that. Not only
that. Look, look at what they've done on
purpose. They put his Look, look, they
put his book there. Enemy of the state.
Look, you see that? It's intentional.
And you will never defeat Islam. You
will never, Patrick, you little pet. You
will never cuz you know why?
Theologically, you're finished. Yes.
Your trinity does not make sense. And
people are flocking to Islam and you're
never going to stop Islam. Fly to
wherever you like. But that title of the
book is correct. He is an enemy of the
state. He's an enemy of the UK. Exactly.
Cuz he's a pro. He's pro Zionist. He's
Israel first. The money from Saudi
Arabia. They're going to convert your
youth. And when they convert your youth
through the prison system on the
streets, they're going to turn them so
quickly and so fast against America and
against your own. It's your own culture.
And Jews, my friend. This is where look,
I cannot wait. I hope I see you again.
You know why? Cuz you're a Christian man
now. Okay. You you [__] You talk about
values. You're a Christian man. Even
though you said, "Oh, you don't have to
be a you don't have to follow Jesus."
What the hell are you talking about,
bro? You made your own Christianity.
You're a Christian. Okay, simple
question. Do you know in their Talmud,
in their scriptures, your God Jesus that
you say, "Let's go back to Jesus. We
need back to Jesus. Everything was made
because of Christianity and all our
values." Okay. Do you know they say that
Jesus is boiling in his own feces in
hellfire? Do you know they say don't say
feces? Because some people don't know
what that means. What does Oh, pew pew.
Yeah. Yes. Okay. This is his crowd.
Exactly. This you don't understand this
kind of words. Yes. Okay. They call his
mother an adulterer. You flipping [__]
Muslims are the ones that are saying to
your youth not to be degenerate to fix
their lives. Okay? This is why we give
da in less square where people are going
and trying to have glimpses of fun and
depressed and they got anxiety and so
much stuff. We call them to the way of
Islam and they come and accept and
become actual human beings, not zombies.
And you're on a big platform and you're
saying, "Oh, you don't have to be you
don't have to believe in Jesus." And not
only that, the very people that you
serve with money are insulting your
faith, my friend. They're insulting the
Jesus that you spit on you in Israel.
They spit on your people. I dare you.
Look, I let me do a social experiment. I
will fund it, bro. I will fund it
personally. That's generous. No, it is.
I I promise you I will fund you to go to
Israel, go as a Christian, wear a cross
and go to certain neighborhoods. They
will spit on you. I will see. They spit
on your face. You know why? Cuz they see
you as an idol worshipper. You scum.
Hatred thing. It's become fashionable.
Do you know what's not fashionable? I
get so much. I think I don't get any
benefit from it. I'm just speaking the
truth. I when I grew up in Luton, the
Islamic jihadist center is the old
synagogue. Okay? I have seen so much Jew
hatred in my hometown. I remember there
was a young family remembering the
Holocaust and it was on the anniversary
of they were having some date and all
the jihadists turned up and the young
family had to lock himself inside the
town hall. He doesn't. He called me a
jihadi. Bro, let me say something. This
is absolute bull crap. I've been a
Muslim for 13 years. I have never been
taught to hate Jews cuz they're Jews.
This is bull crap. This is nonsense. No
one I don't teach my kids and go, "Hey,
listen. Today we're not going to
memorize Quran. We're not going to what
we're going to do today is we're going
to hate the Jews." Yeah. You know, Jews,
we hate No Muslim family that I know,
nobody ever is taught to hate Jews. And
guess what? Who hates Jews? The
Christians, cuz they believe you killed
their god. They believe that you killed
their god. And this infidel crusaders
would massacre Jews. So this is a big
fat lie. But anyways, I don't know any
Jewish gangs selling her. I don't know
any Jewish rape gangs raing away for our
country. I don't know any bad Jews, my
friend. You know about Jews. There are
Zionists in America who were pedophiles
who have the right to return home. Do
you know how many pedophile Americans
are frying back to Israel and run away
from the justice system? Do you know
this, bro? They have pedophile rings.
Not only that, that girl who got raped
by six, seven, was it an IDF? I can't
remember. A British girl who were raped
by six, seven IDF uh soldiers, Israelis
on holiday, did you hear about you
bastard? Did you talk about you scum?
What if that was your daughter? You know
what he'll say? If that was his daughter
being raped by those men, IDF, you know,
he will say he say, "Oh, they funded
me." No, he would have said, "What was
my daughter doing there?" Exactly. You
shouldn't have gone there. Exactly. You
scum. You scum. Did you speak out
against that? No, you didn't. And even
people who are affected by the whole
grooming situation, I don't know what
that girl's name was who was being
bullied by them. Even her kids to be
thrown into the uh the the temps or
something like that. I forgot her name.
Yes. Even her, she was saying that why
you keep talking about only Asian
grooming gangs when they were also white
groomers as well. You're taking away,
you're making it seem as this. Oh, it's
only Asians. We only bother Asian. Like
that man in was in Liverpool who ran
over um some um people with his car. It
was in Liverpool. It happened after a
match. I think it was Liverpool. Yeah,
it was Liverpool. It was Oh, what was
the far right saying? Oh, it's a
terrorist and Muslim Muslim. The moment
they find out it was a white guy, it's
fine. It's one of us. One of us can rape
us. One of us can be a pedophile. One of
us can run us off. As long as it's not
Muslim. Yeah, her name is Caitlyn
Spencer. Caitlin Spencer. That's it.
That's her. And she even spoke about
this. I don't know any Jewish gangs
herin. I don't know any Jewish rape
gangs raping away for our country. I
don't know any bad Jews. I know Islamic
out of control jihadist criminals
terrorizing our nation from one of the
other. And somehow they want to blame
that on the Jews as well.
Bro, look how he drinks the water. You
know he's lying, bro. Stressed out, bro.
I will fund you. I'm telling you. I'll
pay you economic costs to Israel. That's
after if Iran starts foreign ballistic
missiles. Yeah. Then no business card.
Give him business. No, no, I can't do
business. No. Sorry. If hijab want to
chip in, maybe. Okay. No business class
for this come back. He should sit next
to the aisle, next to the toilet. Yeah.
Okay. So, when he goes there, I want him
to go to any Israeli area and write
crisis king. Bro, watch what happens to
you, bro. Bro, watch what happens to
you. I'll pay for that. Tate's reasoning
is because you know you've known Tate
you know for his brother stays being a
Christian but Tate leaves when he goes
to jail and he says the people that
wrote me letters were Muslims but not a
single Christian person wrote me a
letter when I was Muslim. Have you
spoken to him about it or no? So I
believe Christian Christian leadership
has failed us but I believe there's a
revival happening right now in Great
Britain when I make a mini documentary
on it. Something's happening. Something
real big is happening. We went to our
demonstration 100,000 people and there
was a lad king banner and the whole
place was erupted and then I looked at
100,000 people chanting Christ King in
the middle of F. This is unthinkable
unseen. Something's happening. When you
have your loss of identity, loss of
culture and you feel a threat, people
are looking back to where it's come
from. Church is a but the church
leadership are traitors to us in many of
them. We need masking masculine
Christianity. I think with Andrew Tate,
he's a chess player. And I think that
when he was when he was deplatformed,
I'd love to have a discussion with
Andrew, but personally on it, we're
going to disagree on a lot. Me and we go
back years, but we're going to disagree
on a lot because I think that when
Andrew Tate, he made a comment that um
he didn't realize the influence he had
when he when he used to make videos. And
this is when he got deplatformed and he
if he could do it again, he made think
more careful about what he's saying.
Yet, there he is telling people drawing
people to Islam. Now, if Andrew Tate now
decided he didn't believe in Islam, you
didn't believe a word of it. He can't
even come out and say it. They'll kill
him. He can't become the most famous
prophet in the world. He'd be dead. They
want him more. They want me. You think
they'll kill him? 100%. He'd be the
biggest target. It's funny, man. I'm I'm
going to end that dead, man. That's just
so stupid, bro, because he knows a lot
of people that profess to not being
Muslim and they haven't been killed.
Like, this argument, honestly, these are
drawn out, boring arguments that are
repeated again and again. And you know
what? I think it's an insult to his own
crowd, to his own followers that
actually believe this stuff. I think you
guys are to blame the people that still
follow him because that's the reason why
he hasn't picked up a book and that's
the reason why he hasn't improved his
argumentation and the guy is still stuck
in the past. Exactly, man. I I'll be
honest with you. I if I see you on the
street, Tom Robinson, I'm going to come
to you again and surprise attack you
again. You know why? Cuz you're a
Christian man. You're a new man. Before
you was not a Christian. What do you
mean by surprise attack? Surprise. Not
surprise attack. Intellectual surprise
attack. Yeah, he knows. I mean, bro, if
you hit him stupid if you hit him, half
will go to waste. I'm gen half will go
to waste. Yeah. And and let me be honest
with you, intellectual slap will hit you
harder. Uh like when I confronted you in
that court case, you was excuse me, you
scrapping yourself. Okay, I'm going to
do this this time, but you as a
Christian version, Tom is a Christian
version. You know why? Cuz I want to
hear your opinions. You talked about
apostasy. Yeah, my friend. You're you're
a Christian man now. The Bible is all
yours. It says kill, you know,
apostates. You've got the apostate laws
there. You know, you've got the numbers.
uh uh 19 verse uh 31 numbers 31 verse 18
my friend I want to know your opinion
about the very people that you defend
the Zionist yes the Talmud about your
god I cannot wait to see your face my
friend if you're a real Christian if
you're a real Christian a follow of
Christ I dare you to answer that inshah
and if you want to come to my dial table
leester square every Friday and Sunday I
challenge you and your little in your
intellectual midgets to come and tell us
that we Muslims are harmful we want the
best for the British youth and I mean
this genuinely do you know how many come
and they're gambling addicts, alcohol
addicts, unhappy. There was one man came
wah he broke he was on the verge of
suicide. We had to talk him out of it.
Yes. I didn't come and say he's a
British man. We said his life is dear.
All says in the Quran if he saved one
sol as if he saved the whole of
humanity. We want the best for the
British people. The country has come to
such a level that they need a minister
for loneliness. For God's sake, we
cannot make that. They have a minister
for loneliness. Ladies and gentlemen,
even if you look at the population
because they're talking about lowering
fertility rates, there are more dogs in
people's homes than there are children.
Subhan Allah. I mean, and even in this
interview when you've got a big
platform, invite the people to
Christianity. What does he say? Oh, you
don't you don't really have to believe
in Jesus. I'll be happy. I'll be happy
to live on the Christian rule. I've just
they're the people of the book. I'd be
happy, bro. All day instead of liberals
and flipping transgenders and flipping
LGBT teaching my kids all kind of
flipping crazy degenerate stuff. I'd
rather in Christianity, even if we we
will say we don't believe them and we
believe that is far worse in the sense
by the theology. Yeah. But at least
you're not drilling it down by force.
Subhan Allah. So to be honest, we have
no issue. But anyways, um Tommy Robinson
and I don't even know why he's in this
island. I don't know where he's run away
from. But anyways, it's probably those
letters that were sent by Muhammad to
his house. Um anyways, inshallah, we'll
see you. You're going to have to clarify
that because people might not know. No,
it's letters. It's not like can you
write a letter? No, is he suing him?
Yes. He's legally suing him and we will
see him in court. Till next timealam
sisters, if you enjoy this video, give
it a thumbs up.
[Music]